these are called rational functions can
anyone tell me why we call them rational
functions rationally think back to our
first lesson when we do our copy numbers
and real numbers and rational numbers
were kind of number what a rational
numbers they're like fractions is that
right two thirds and a half and three
and five five eighths or something like
that there's a rational numbers these
are rational functions be closed they
are ratios between different functions
now we're going to tease out how to draw
these and the principles like I think
most of you with some time could draw
these without my help but I'm going to
try and draw out some principles that
hopefully make it more efficient and
help you to get the right answers the
right sort of finish off quicker okay
right let's have a look at this now
we're under the your multiplication and
division so each of these you can see is
not just a division of this and this but
there's also a halt on a multiplication
happening right the lattice what makes
it the most obvious right because you
see there's this time this does this
it's not so obvious in these so the
first thing we do is to put this in the
form that makes the multiplication Bob
you straight in other words we want to
factorize ok to have a look at this top
one it's not make than Joeckel so let's
make it an arrow how can I factorize the
numerator yeah I can just take out na
right you're probably thinking about if
I'd done that okay if I take out an X
that's going to leave me with x 14 can I
factorizing fell no dumb ok dena now
this looks like X minus 2 X minus 3 okay
you happy good now we factorize that's
the first important step and I'm going
to use this as an acronym that I've been
using for a while which is which is
quite helpful which is that you want
your graphs to look feather fares a very
old-fashioned work we tend to use it
like it's not fair I only got a third of
a party you've got two birds we mean
ferreted equity but there has another
old fashioned means anyone know it means
beauty right so something is fair
fairies the coming so fair actually
stands for something the first letter
you've already done which is factorize
okay so effing factorize the a stands
for a really important feature to it
actually which are really easy to find
now we've factorized it mainly i'm
looking now two asymptotes okay
asymptotes so your factorized now we're
going to look for asymptotes now there
are three kinds of asymptotes that you
guys know about three kinds but there
are actually really two categories
ketone with the three kinds of vertical
horizontal or oblique okay good so this
is the three kinds so it's like ok these
ones are up down these ones are left to
right and these guys are like offered a
reader hookie angle ok that's fine but
actually even though they look like
they're three different things these
guys are really two versions of the same
thing and this one is very very
different let me try to justify the food
vertical asymptotes come from have a
look this graph is going to have two
vertical asymptotes can you see how I
know what they are yeah it's going two
and three it comes from the denominator
right a vertical asymptote means it's
part of the domain restriction you can't
go there you can't put two or three in
it breaks down okay so i'm going to
write is vertical asymptotes
and i've got x equals two x equals 3
okay now a function can have can have as
many vertical asymptotes as you like you
could have got to hear you could have
one you could have a hundred right how
would i add more vertical asymptotes to
a function or have you yeah just put
more stuff in the denominator right put
in X minus 1 at x + 1 X however many
times you do that you're going to get
lots of those in fact a very famous
function you know about has an infinite
number of vertical asymptotes because
it's periodic Zen or known before the
other we're thinking of 10 because 10 is
also a rational function do you see it
as a rational function so every time
this denominator is 0 which is a lot of
times okay then then you get a very
presentation yes so that's the first
thing you wanna learn about these you
can have loads and loads and loads of
them and um they represent a restriction
I medomak let's contrast that to a
horizontal or oblique as well now i
happen to know and you're going to work
it out a second to that this does not
have an oblique asymptote he has a
horizontal a surgery does anyone know
what it is
so remembering our vocalist up down
lines that's why there xmms horizontal
asymptotes are all in the form y equals
something in this case but y is equal to
1 how do I know there's lots of ways you
can analyze this there are going to two
ways that I'm gonna tell you about just
quickly there's one way you divide
everything by like saying this paste
into my aromatics quit you can do that
I'm okay with that I have never found
that to be the way that clicks with my
mind here's what I prefer and hopefully
I can justify number one the horizontal
asymptote all the obligatory right you
remember I lump them together okay in
the middle of the function right so
here's a famous one that you guys know
this guy has a vertical asymptote and
has a horizontal asymptote right in fact
this picture is so easy to know under
this kind of actually jumps into your
mind as soon as you see it right now we
all know what the horizontal acetone is
this guy tell me what is the relevance
of the horizontal asymptote any of the
middle of the graph like around here
what relevance does it have an answer is
it has none right the function doesn't
care about the horizontal asymptote in
the middle in fact for this particular
example races away from the asymptotes
right which is not what asymptotes I
supposed to do in fact horizontal
oblique asymptotes they only tell you
what's going on not in the middle but at
the edges here right as you're going to
positive infinity or negative infinity
and the word that sometimes textbook
uses the extremities the extreme parts
of the graph that's what the horizontal
or oblique asymptotes tell you now for
that reason while you can have loads and
loads and loads of vertical asymptotes
you can only ever have one horizontal or
oblique asymptote this one that's it I
don't need to go and find other ones
this is the only thing that'll approach
okay now how do I know that it's one
that approaches and not two or three or
four
okay so as we mentioned you could divide
by x squared and get something out of
that but something I prefer to do is
being that it's about extreme values
just take an extreme value and
substitute it in a thousand a million
something like that ok now let's just
have a look at the unpacked eyes form
for a second do you notice that these
guys here they're negative 4x the minus
4x the minus 5x and the six okay they
are important but not when X is a really
big number do you notice that right like
for example say 26 okay if i put x is
like a million into here this is going
to be a million million who cares if
that this 6 it's just going to be so an
unimportant okay even these guys then
they grow they don't grow anything in
comparison to these guys right so these
are the ones that are really important
do you agree and that's why you maybe
you want to circle this because it's so
important that's why when you first
learned that for them is we bothered to
give that term and name we call it the
bleeding terms right things only get
names in mathematics or in any area of
knowledge when they matter for some
reason and this is the reason they
matter the leading term tells you
everything you need to know about the
horizontal asymptote all people gasping
to one's x square on the top there's an
expert on the bottom as they get bigger
then get bigger at exactly the same rate
right so since you're dividing through
you just get that it's that make sense
what if don't write this because make it
message what if I this was a two down
here what would happen as I put huge
huge value Z yeah well they're both this
is a one up here which we don't write
they're both going exactly the same rate
the one will stay there in the two
statement lets you just get a hot or if
I made this like you know eight over
three you're just going to get eight
thirds right whatever ok so those values
there they tell you what you're headed
towards so that's one okay factorize you
work out the asymptotes that's it ok I
come on big your graphing what's
important
RAF it intercepts that you're not now we
read the asymptotes of the denominator
and also may prepare considering the
whole thing together right where are you
going to read the Interceptor yeah when
x equals y equals zero you factorized so
you've already made part of this easy
for you do you see that i can say x
equals 0 and x equals 4 here are my
intercepts right x equals 0 x equals 4
they're going to be my x-intercepts um
since i've got x equals 0 that means
it's also a y-intercept dinner that's
that's the origin okay so um there we go
I've got all the intercepts I want